Frank Isola the star of around the horn
Sirius XM NBA radio the starting lineup
Monday through Friday and Frank kind
enough to join us here Frank can you
help me understand what's going on with
Spike Lee and the New York Knicks I want
to know and how are you Dan since you're
you're a media guy but you're also a
celebrity VIP Dan Patrick enter the
garden through the VIP entrance order
you enter with the riffraff of the media
and you go at 8 Penn Plaza which one is
it
well all those years I worked at CNN and
I would go over I went through the
employee entrance a couple of times but
it wasn't with me with people like me
the Rif rep I've been on the elevator
before it spike he's entered that way a
million times and I know you know spike
and Spike listen the Panisse courtside
does he like being part of the show some
people don't like it some people do but
when Spike is like kind of behind the
scenes so to speak he doesn't walk
around like he owns Madison Square
Garden and he's been coming in that way
forever
what first of all what's the big deal
right but you have a new rule but for
the story to get to the point that it's
at and whether or not the Knicks were
100 percent right or spike is 100
percent right it's the Knicks that don't
look good because what the Knicks are
trying to do is kind of market
themselves to NBA players so now you
have they gave Charles Oakley a hard
time threw him out of the building and
after giving a whom to the most famous
fan entering the building it makes no
sense Frank could you imagine the Cubs
doing this to Bill Murray yes or you
know the Lakers are Jack Nicholson no
honey you're 100% right that's a great
way of looking at it what do you have to
gain from doing something like that and
remember this - you know there are times
where they can give the media a hard
time which I you know I get it you know
the team hasn't been good really for 20
years and the coverage is even though
they don't want to admit this the
coverage is based on the result so the
results have been for the most part
really bad for the last 20 years so the
relationship between the media and the
team is not going to be that great
obviously I mean the relationship
between the Warriors and their media the
last five years has been pretty good
because they went to the finals in five
straight years so a lot of times it
comes down to the results but regardless
of the relationship between the media
and the team here's a guy that's paying
money
Simar it's like I think he said like 300
was it the three grand per ticket he's
got two per game you know it's a lot of
money over the course of the year maybe
like in his lifetime since he's been a
Knick fan he's maybe spent 10 million
dollars he's basically paid for a power
forwards I mean it's a lot of money I
mean what's the big in the grand scheme
of things it's not a big deal but it is
a big deal like well like why go through
this on the night where Leon Rose takes
over the team you have your best win of
the season against the eastern rockets
and what becomes a big story that the
owner of the team and the most famous
fan are getting into that that's really
what you want he actually pays for this
poor product you know other people right
it's yeah he pays for this and if he is
an employee Frank he might be unofficial
but he's been the ambassador for the
Knicks for almost 30 years and I so I
don't know how it got to this point but
it just feels like it's a Knicks way of
handling things and that's why they're
the worst run franchising and probably
in all the sports and even when he went
on the air yesterday the kind of you
know to explain himself
in the complaint about it he was wearing
Nick stuff he was wearing you know a
Knicks he cap yeah he still kind of
represents the Knicks everywhere he goes
and there's nothing a gain from it and
you know for them to come out and say in
the statement that is laughable why why
pick a fight with him whine in you this
thing it doesn't it doesn't make any
sense but it kind of gives you an
indication of where the Knicks are right
now and a big thing for them Dan over
you know last summer was you know they
struck out with free agents and just the
perception that a lot of NBA players
have about the necks and it was really
hurt by the Charles Oakley situation
when they throw them out of the building
and again let's say for example it's
let's argue than excited that they're
100 percent right and what they did they
still hurt themselves in the eyes of NBA
players you had LeBron James the most
powerful player in the league came out
and said something about a Chris Paul
also the second most powerful player in
the league came out and said something
about it why would you want that to
forget about how the media feels about
you and whatever fans who sit me up or
deck the idea is
for you to go out and get players that's
not how you want to be perceived but
that's how they are proceed we're
talking to Frank Isola who covers the
NBA and contributes to around the horn
couple other things here Tim Duncan
takes over for Coach Popovich in San
Antonio as Papi's out for personal
reasons
do you think Tim Duncan is the successor
the heir apparent to Gregg Popovich in
San Antonio no earlier this season and
it really floated under the radar I
believe it was against Portland that
there was a home game where Gregg
Popovich got kicked out and it was
pretty clear that either Tim Duncan or
will Hardy is a the guys and went to
Williams College which is same College
but the kid Duncan Robinson went there
before he went to my Michigan is also
George Sarris college anyway it was
clear that they were kind of coaching
the team and I thought it was
interesting that nobody really made a
connection where one was it was Becky
Hammon gonna be the next one but it does
seem like maybe Tim Duncan it's
something that he wants to do clearly
he's an assistant coach and I think he
wants to be part of the NBA I thought he
handled himself really well because Dan
they said that he wasn't going to speak
and after the game he spoken you can
tell why his teammates loved him as a
teammate because he comes across the
self deprecating he credited the other
coaches for what they did he said you
know all I was doing was screaming
nonsensical stuff like that's attending
Duncan perfectly and he looks great and
he's lost from his playing days not that
he was petty but he's clearly lost
weight he's got the cool hair working
what I said though what the delete'
should have done they should have had
Joey Crawford show up as a referee
remember Joey kicked them out of that
game now man all Tim Duncan was saying
something from the bench would be buried
like if he did coach a bunch of games it
would be interesting to see what his
interaction would be like with the
referees but I'm still convinced the
Spurs next game is in New York
Gregg Popovich loves coming to New York
hanging out the restaurants drinking
wine he probably came you probably
decided just to come to New York a
couple of days early
Ronnie's Brooklyn I don't know if this
was a topic going around the horn but
I'm gonna guess it was with the LeBron
versus Greek freak MVP [ __ ] where do you
stand meanest well you know it's funny
like LeBron as opposed to
doesn't really have kind of the media
machine behind them visit Rihanna's
doesn't really go out I don't know if
the right word is to recruit or to
cultivate other people in the media if
you talk to him he's fine
but I think LeBron and now LeBron's an
older player so he has more
relationships but I do think that LeBron
is smart because LeBron did not have a
great game on Saturday night against
Memphis now the game was on national TV
nobody paid attention to it and they
lost the game but you know this game
were a lot of eyeballs are on he's going
up again diana has a great game that
same day
giannis goes for 40 I think it was 41
and 20 so Yanis has had the better game
but a lot of people in the media then
listen all of us that you know once you
start getting a little bit older you
kind of appreciate guys out of 35 years
old it could still do it at the highest
level but that really shouldn't factor
into the voting it really should come
down to who's having the better season
and let's remember this - who would you
rather have as your second teammate
Chris Middleton or Anthony Davis so he's
got the better second teammate and I
also think the media votes for awards
and a lot of times we like to you know
we sometimes vote with a little sense of
what's the better story and I do think
of abroad winning it would probably be
the better story but I do get a vote and
as of this moment that doesn't mean it
can't change I would still vote Yanis as
the MVP because what he's doing is
incredible and they had 52 wins which is
pretty remarkable yeah I think the
storyline the story angle is pretty
important here and having voted on this
before you know when Karl Malone won I
voted for Jordan and when Charles won I
voted for Jordan the better story was
Charles Barkley in the Suns the better
story was Karl Malone in the Utah Jazz
but you can't tell me that Jordan wasn't
the most valuable player LeBron is the
most valuable player in the NBA and has
been for probably 12 years his value is
true value for every single franchise in
the NBA and what he's doing for his team
for a guy who doesn't want doesn't want
to be listed as a point guard he's taken
over that position and he's leading the
league in assists he's got three years
of playoff basketball three seasons
added on to that 35 year old body I
I mean I don't know what you factor in
but I got a factor in all of these
things here and Anthony Davis hasn't
been healthy there's no drama with the
Lakers and I I don't know I I think I
understand what you're saying but look
at you know look at the numbers that now
is putting up be honest is so dominant
that he's just over 30 minutes a night
and a lot of times he doesn't have to
play the fourth quarter because he's
done so much damage so the win total
should have something to do with it but
again his second-best teammate is Chris
Middleton and I get it Chris Middleton
but the Lakers are winning the West
Frank
the Bucs are winning the East good teams
in East I mean Miami's a good team
tomorrow is a good team Philadelphia is
a good team they're still good teams
they're who's in the Western Conference
Denver's the second best team they just
lost last I know to Golden State the
Clippers never have all their guys well
when it's all said and done when we get
to the postseason the postseason will be
tougher to go through the Westin East I
think we can agree on that right well I
mean yeah I guess it would be if Memphis
finishes eighth that's a pretty easy
personal series I would love to see
Portland get it because if you're the
Lakers you go through the season with
the best record in the West and then you
have to play Damian Lillard CJ McCollum
to a team that was in the Western
Conference hell no we want the pelicans
we want the pelicans in at that HC well
so does the league in Turner and ESPN
will be very happy at the league office
very happy Frank keep the peace on
around the horn and of course at Madison
Square Garden play nice all right Thank
You Frank Frank isola ESPN's around the
horn sirius XM NB a radio the starting
lineup Monday through Friday